In this video I want
to find different ways of expressing the person
of this whole large rectangle,
which we see is composed of these six smaller rectangles.
There are several ways we can do it.
One is simply to multiply the height
of this large rectangle along its width.
And what is his height?
It is from here to here,
this distance is u ^ 2,
and then from there to there,
this distance is -6u.
And I know what you think.
How can the distance be -6?
Is not the distance always positive?
Well even-may be positive,
if u is negative,
so it's perfectly reasonable to say,
that this distance can be -6u.
So, the whole height is here
y2-6u.
Or you can write it as u ^ 2 plus this distance,
which is -6u,
y2 plus + 6y,
which is the same as y2-6u.
Therefore this is the height of this large rectangle.
What is his breadth?
Well, the width is
the width
of this purple rectangle,
it is 3u ^ 2,
plus the width of this yellow rectangle,
which is -2u,
which may be minus,
the logic of why it may be negative is the same
as here, why can it be negative.
And then plus
the width of the blue rectangle.
And if you bring them all together,
the width of the entire rectangle will be
3u ^ 2-2u + 1.
So the expression I just wrote,
will give us the face of the whole big rectangle.
There is another way to find it.
One big hint is that this big rectangle
is divided into these six smaller rectangles
and we have the dimensions of the six smaller rectangles.
So we can find the faces of each of them
and then gather them all together.
Let's take a look at this one.
Height of breadth.
The face of this purple rectangle is
the height y2
in the width which is 3th in square.
This is equal to ... it will be three ...
and then u ^ 2 by u ^ 2 is u ^ 4.
What is the face of this yellow rectangle?
The height is u ^ 2.
This is u ^ 2 in the width,
on -2y,
which will give us -2u ^ 3.
What about blue?
The height of the width is u ^ 2 at one,
which simply equals y ^ 2.
On this green rectangle
the face is the height that is now -6u,
on a width that is 3 ^ y2,
which will be equal to: -6 at 3 is -18,
and then u by u ^ 2 is u ^ 3.
The face of the gray rectangle is
the height that is -6u,
on the width that is -2u,
what gives us ...
-6 by -2 is plus 12.
u is u ^ y ^.
Finally, the face of this rectangle here,
is the height that is -6u,
in width, which is just one,
which is equal to -6u.
And to get the face of this entire rectangle,
we can just assemble the faces of the smaller ones,
so it will be equal to:
3rd on the fourth,
3u ^ 4 plus -2u ^ 3 ...
Let me write it in a color that matches it.
-2u ^ 3
plus y ^ 2
-18u ^ 3 ...
and so, -18u-3,
plus 12u ^ 2 ...
Let me write it in black.
Plus 12u ^ 2,
and then finally, but not least,
we have -6u.
This is the expression of the face of all this,
but we can still simplify it.
We have only one member of the fourth degree,
so I'll just copy it.
We have a fourth degree member,
so I just rewrite it.
3u ^ 4.
How many third grade members do we have?
We have -2u ^ 3.
We have -18u ^ 3.
If I gather them together,
how much of a third degree will we have?
Well -2 plus -18 is -20,
minus 20u ^ 3.
And then how many second grade members do we have?
We have one u ^ 2 here
and then we have another 12u ^ 2.
We collect them together and get 13u ^ 2.
And finally, we have to pull out six.
And we got it,
another expression for the face of the entire rectangle.
The whole reason I do this is to realize,
that this up here and here below are equivalent,
and that the way we multiply it is actually in line
exactly the way we found the faces
of the smaller rectangles here.
You can say that u ^ 2 by 3u ^ 2 is 3u ^ 4.
y2 in -2y is -2u ^ 3.
u ^ 2 one is u ^ 2.
This is exactly the same thing we did,
when we found the faces of these rectangles.
I suppose we can say,
in this top row.
And then we'll take -6th
and we can say that -6u by 3u ^ 2
is -18.
-6 on -2u is plus 12u ^ 2.
-6u at one is -6u.
I describe it to realize that we are not doing here
some kind of magic.
This makes sense when you look at it
thus with respect to the formula for a person.